يمكنك أن تقول ما نفعله الآن يا
بيتر ، ما الذي كنا نقود به على
جانب الجبل في سيارة رولز رويس
التي هي حقًا
غريبة عن
شوارع باريسية ومنتجعات ساحلية ساحرة
تريد رولز رويس أن تأخذك إلى
مكان ما لم تفعله.  لقد كنت منذ أول
بلد بري في الحرب العالمية ،
قدت للتو على جانب جبل
في Rolls Royce of SUVs ، وليس
حرفياً Rolls Royce Cullinan ، وهي سيارة
تحمل كلمات Rolls-Royce تقول إنهم لم
يعتادوا على الإعجاب بالعملية المتعددة الاستخدامات
على الطرق الوعرة كما هو الحال مع جميع سيارات رولز رويس ، فإن
كولينان ذات الدفع الرباعي لا تفتقر أبدًا إلى
الثقة أو القوة حتى عند القيادة على
ممر جبلي شديد الانحدار ، فإن الكبح
يستجيب للتوجيه وحسمًا ، قد
لا أتسلق وجه إل كابيتان ولكن
بالنسبة لأدوارنا ، هذا هو الموت-  تحديًا
وإذا لم يبدو هذا مخيفًا ، ضع في اعتبارك
أننا نسير على الطرق الوعرة في شيء
يبدأ من ثلاثمائة وخمسة وعشرين
ألف دولار ، كان كولينان
مذهلاً عند صعوده جانب أحد
الجبال  بعد أن كان معظم
زبائنه يقودون هذه السيارة ،
فإن التحدي الذي يواجه رولز رويس هو أن
يتمكنوا من صنع سيارة قادرة على
القيام بذلك ولكن على الطريق لا يزال لديها
تلك السجادة السحرية الشهيرة
لشيء قد
يتسخ ، فإن كولينان هي بالتأكيد السيارة  معظم سيارات
رولز رويس مثل سيارات الدفع الرباعي التي مررت بها
على الطريق ، فإن كولينان هادئة يتم
التحكم فيها بالكثير والكثير
من القوة ، لكن إذا قارنت
جودة الركوب في هذا بشبح أو فانتوم
من رولز رويس ، فهذا مرتفع جدًا  شريط
لكن Cullinan لا
يجعل ما يفتقر إليه Cullinan
هو العزلة القصوى التي
يحصل عليها المرء عادة داخل رولز رويس ، إنه حقًا
ما يجعل رولز رويس ساحرًا هذا
الشعور بأنه معزول عن
العالم في شرنقة  من الفخامة الباهظة
والصقل المطلق وفقًا للمعايير العادية ،
فإن Cullinan مريح بشكل مثير للدهشة ،
ولكن وفقًا لمعايير رولز رويس ، يبدو الأمر
مجرد لمسة مألوفة بشكل جيد وهذا أمر
مخزٍ على الرغم من أنني ما زلت أتوقع أن
Cullinan  مع كل ما تم اكتشافه حديثًا من
عملية ومرونة ،
ستأخذ روح النشوة إلى أماكن
لم تكن فيها منذ وقت طويل جدًا